so today I'm Scrooge report Ohio though
it's my last video we did a video on who
was the most detestable vegan let's see
if we can top the charts today let us
know at which point you want to check
out of this video and buy an all mean
worst thing to all the other thing but a
stereotype I'm saying that all feelings
are this thing order now let's go see it
stereotypical vegan I get offended
seeing pints of milk I physically can't
look at cheese it mid-sentence like
shivers down my spine I can't look at
cheese it sends shivers down my you are
listening for Shakespeare what is this
you can look at cheese my dude what is
you talking about I've been called the
n-word multiple times in my life I can
still watch slave movies calm down
[Music]
I've been brought up around farming
since then I was born I'm passionate and
producing food to feed the country and
the rest of the world I've been brought
up around farm in my entire life and as
a result I'm proud to be part of feeding
the country and feeding the world
British farmers have some of the highest
standards of animal welfare traceability
and environmental protection than any
other farmers anywhere in the world at
the same time we don't tell people what
they should eat we grow what they want
to eat people should have access to
accurate information and be able to make
their own decisions in terms of what
they want to eat and how they should
live their lives dude I understand your
perspective what do you think about the
ability to essentially clone flesh and
replicate the taste of an animal I guess
would you consider you wanna sit down
can you sit and talk face to face would
you like that I feel great about losing
the challenge I'd like to continue the
conversation there if you okay yeah let
me get another chair just look at Josh
like I didn't sign up for this I thought
I was gonna look at the back of his head
now you got me talking to this crazy I
feel bad for John the producers like oh
we got it here's the thing josh is like
this is why I live far away from the
city
cuz some people like you I would want to
live on a farm tube this is what I see
when I come to town nice to meet you
nice to sit on that one when I shake his
hand I could feel the suffering that
those son was hard to meet you okay I
don't think this is a real person what
do you think there's a bunch of murder
detectives that wish they could touch it
murders hand me like I could feel the
suffering of Stacey as you choked her
out I know good actor good acting good
job rough but no no no we look him up
Nick the car is a London born
multidisciplinary creative and recording
artists known as
oh wow it's a real person
this is like watching an unfamous con
you rent you know the flesh clothing I
think you should leave the UK in
developing that technology if you
develop that then then you'll need like
one beautiful cow that it's like the
most sacred cow in the whole world that
delivers me to everyone do I mean like
that would be amazing cuz you know how
sentient these creatures are they just
want a love that's all they want they
just want love I bet you there's a cow
somewhere watching this be like not a
guy just wanna like there's gotta be
some animals out there who want a lot
more than just love Nick like you ever
just try to go up to a lie and be like a
[ __ ] you want some love and the lion
eats you
you think the lion just wants love not
lion wants to bone it wants to eat it
wants to start up all this yeah I feel
like we're watching a mentally ill
person acceptable mentally I completely
respect some of these decision I cool to
live a vegan lifestyle to me it's just
the same as voting for who you want to
vote for worshipping what God you want
to worship marrying here you want to
make sure for sure for sure I understand
all that I understand that you're a farm
and you love your livelihood and you
feel like everyone should be left and
what do you want to do for sure for sure
well if we had a whole cow that we did
for sure it's fake compassion for sure
for sure I could definitely feel the
cow's suffering on your hands for sure
for me choosing what diet you have and
what lifestyle you live falls into that
I'm all look for pursuing other options
in terms of how we're gonna feed the
world
but the animals that I've been around my
entire life have been farmed in a way
that's fair I don't see why the way
we've produced food whether that be beef
or dairy or lamb needs to be replaced by
that technology you do see that as the
inevitable future right personally not I
could see it could be but I mean I can't
read that I don't have a crystal ball so
I can't see what if I have a crystal
ball
you know one thing I can't stand its
people that know they have to in shoes
oh you don't I do
cuz I have to choose because I do I'm
righteous my past is the yo I can't
stand people that have this they just
think that dirty it's funny because this
mother right there is like oh yeah you
know what we're equal who the same as
animals we're equal we're equal yet you
feel higher and superior than either me
humans thinking no I have a crystal ball
I know you don't that's me cuz I got the
power stuff cup oh I can't stand that
Mama's gonna look at you like oh yeah
yeah oh you oh you know you don't know
what if you don't know now I know you
know what I mean and if you don't know
now you know the truth is the one oh man
obviously nick has a crystal ball that
it can use to see into the future I
don't have that talent
I'm excited if you can read the future
because I certainly can't okay you yeah
you can't you eat meat it's a vegan
thing it's a super probably I just being
understanding why did I stay here what
was your point when you sat down and you
pulled the chair what was your point at
that point was it to just be that don't
want to have a conversation and be like
you know what enough or you just
absolutely wanted a chair change my
views and be right and be absolutely
right and when you fail because there's
no point valid points there and when you
failed miserably you're just gonna be
condescending a little that would is sad
it's not I certainly won't change my
opinion I'm a big believer that British
agriculture is sustainable and fit for
the future and we're constantly striving
to improve it day to day and I also
can't see Nick changing his opinion
anytime
I didn't really don't mind I'd lost the
challenge those miracle Herbalife people
yeah D the back in the day I remember
like he used to come and see my mom I
saw what I was watching whatever I heard
her store and it was like yeah so do you
like to make money the first we got my
card on and then it got cut to go to one
of the reunions three or four times you
just know that y'all that same oh yeah
yeah so you like making money no I'm
good I'm good
Oh what when you turn them down then the
Swiss on you the football you don't want
to make money no I'm good I think I know
what you're gonna offer me I don't want
that I'm good so you don't want to sell
out your friends and family no I don't
I'm good I'm good you you don't want to
steal your friends and family's money
for a pyramid scheme that'll also
benefit you my newly really better
benefit the people on top you yeah no
I'm not about that are you okay are you
okay for sure egg for sure you feed me
bowling I can feel poverty when I
touched his hand I swear to God I could
feel the suffering of poverty you know
what I've been to one show you in my
store dude yeah did I go leave is that
well you see me rollin with my
Lamborghini and you see mine Jim fast
forward two years after that I work for
another company and I work at
collections
guess who calls because his line was cut
and I'm like oh I wish I could invest
like that that's below that's the
beautiful Karma
I can't lie i screenshot of that in 2018
no single human needs an animal product
to survive there's a lot of kids that
are waking up to this fight this is like
a movement and there's gonna be a bunch
of people that are lagging behind and if
you want to be at the forefront of
actual progressive thinking then you
know where to come
it's a fact not a movement not
fad as well as veganism got through
essentially this is speciesism by milk
you are asking someone to cows your
conditioning look at you are a
conversation like that you like milk so
you're okay with the cows whoa how did
we get here what what just happened
you're killin me cows you like honey so
you like beasts Pass
yeah you like it you like it in there
booty hole you like it'll be in the
booty hole you suck on their stinger
till the honey comes out huh I don't
know where honey goes don't ask me to
get off technical ain't no beekeeper
okay
this man escalated so fast
I like badges so you like oppressing
black people the cow is locked in a cage
because you look on the case all this
stuff going on I'm not desensitized to
the language that you're using
I'm all for freedom and liberation no
you're not you're not for freedom and
liberation you're for freedom and
liberation in your own terms
freedom of what freedom of just those
animals but you can't let people speak
you just always going over people and if
they don't think like you they're just
that's not freedom that's not freedom
nobody on this thing is liberated well
you think you are because you should
hire a kind of force and knowledge but
and that's what's wrong with it is that
you probably had some valuable valid
points but because you're so outrageous
with it there's a lot of things that you
say that makes no sense it makes people
not want to hear you I think that we
need to start questioning when there are
alternatives which are actually better
for us as people and better for our
spirits and our minds and our souls and
the future of humanity that's why I
think I think that we should be non
Conner's I think I think cultures all
over the world of practice
have a ball and you guys are living in
the past because of your taste buds and
because of your were like in ability to
order an almond milk all right
so basically the reason why you're here
is because you're stupid no you can't
argue with this guy oh yay
he's definitely worse than Aaron Aaron
was in the context of a game so I could
at least forgive her competitive nature
and trying to get day and try to people
even if she was very detestable this
guy's infinitely worse than her
infinitely worse than I'm cringing for
real
I'm curdling like deep in my spirit I
could just feel Shakira wanting to
scream just oh yeah
oh man my crazy meter and my just like
who who raised your meter listen I think
there's real valid arguments for
veganism on both sides mm-hmm real
arguments it was a way to present them
when you come out here in your life not
the best way to do it nor was the
present he really did top that girl he
topped her easily this was 100 meter
sprint didn't even get started when this
man already crossed the finish line in
his car brother he's not at the Olympics
he's working on some Galactic Olympic
he's competing with aliens I've never
seen somebody that detestable in a video
that impress teittleman's oh man Wow
that's it for today's video tell us what
you guys think we want to hear in the
comments below
you
[Music]